okay I'm gonna read from my novel black
in just the first three sections it's
the three male characters sort of
speaking in turn about their
relationship with the president and the
duties that they belong for him his
portraitist he came every two months for
sitting always early in the day usually
on a Friday when he stole had something
vital in his face from the week's effort
with a mellowness in his eyes from the
knowledge that it was almost over in the
late spring the Fallen Jacaranda
blossoms lay luminous on the pavement
outside at that time of day and his
assistant would scoop them up by the
handful and strew them over the couch
where he sat or lay or lounged for each
portrait regal purple petals made him
feel like a king I always mixed my
palette before he arrived I knew the
shade of his skin the hue of his hair
the pinkness of the half-moons and his
nails after he'd arrived and was seated
I'd adjust the colors slightly according
to his mood if it had been a bad week
his skin Turin needed more yellow if he
was feeling benevolent I had added orb
of blue to the white for his eyes he
said having his picture painted was his
only therapy I would start with the
charcoal sketch of his face I was
ruthless about detail and documented
each new wrinkle or discoloration or
sausage spot but this is what he wanted
in his very first sitting I flattered
him on the canvas and he threatened
never to return so the next time I
painted him as he was and it pleased him
you would be surprised what can happen
to her face in two months
one day I'll bind together all the
surviving charcoal sketches and make a
flipbook that jolts single frames into
action when thumbed quickly the flip
books
we'll be the aging of the president the
oil portraits used to take me exactly
six hours he would decide on his pose
and when he settled into it his
assistant blush at his face oil with
foundation and on days when the
president looked particularly tired
added some authority to his eyes
with eyeliner he had a none can uncouple
it a to sit still for hours at the end
of each session before the paint had
even dried his assistant collected the
portrait to hang next to the flag in
Parliament so that the portrait in
Parliament was always the most current
and the outdated ones were distributed
to dignitaries to hang in their homes
the chef's the president's favorite meal
was Sunday brunch when I would do a
fresh seafood platter for him and serve
it in the private private dining room in
his City apartment not even his family
joined him for this meal we established
a comfortable routine over the years the
guard would let me into the apartment at
9:00 a.m. I brought all the ingredients
uncooked with me and prepared the meal
in his own kitchen as quietly as I could
so as not to wake him I had equipped the
kitchen to meet my needs and two tasks
there that I had long abandoned doing in
the main presidential residence kitchens
things like disemboweling crayfish using
their own feelers
d stop ring sea snails the hitting pawns
these are normally jobs for lowly
kitchen boys but in his quiet kitchen on
a Sunday I grew fond of doing my own
dirty work
I communed with an earlier self thatwe
remembered my own humble beginnings it
reminded me of my respects for processes
the satisfaction of peeling and chopping
and mincing and grating all the myriad
ways one can put a culinary world in
order I can't deny the pride I felt
knowing that each item I prepared in
that kitchen would nourish the president
as soon as I arrived I would place the
live abalone on the floor of the pantry
they were always tense from being
transported and had to calm down before
I could kill them otherwise the flesh
would be tough I would leave them there
until everything else was almost ready
then creep up on them and hit them on
they soft underbellies with the end of a
rolling pin if they Saints me coming
they contracted like a heart muscle and
were wasted his barber the president was
meticulous about his facial hair same
with his ear and nostril hair he
insisted that I used tweezers to dig
deep into his orifices to root out the
hair that source which inevitably
inflicted pain and he swore and threw
things against the wall to cope and
afterward panted like a dog in heat I
secretly suspected he liked it he had a
daily late afternoon appointment with me
in preparation for evening functions his
hair grew fast and blue and by the end
of each day his stubble showed its color
but the air and nostril ritual I
performed only weakly like all men the
president's favorite part of the session
was the lathering the brush I used was
soft but firm and the shaving soap
lathered easily with moisture kneading
little encouragement I made small
circles on his lower face until the soap
firmed I know it felt good
for me the satisfaction was indi
laddering I would sharpen my knife in
front of the president and he would
wince from the sound but he never opened
his eyes to look which could be
interpreted as a sign of either
cowardice or bravery then I would take
his head firmly between my hands and
tilted backward this was the moment I
waited for each day with a brisk twist
of my hands I could have snapped his
neck slit his throat with a knife flick
but I did neither I would start at the
bottom of his neck with the blade and
glided slowly upward watching the
stubble mingle with the firm every
evening the floor of my shop would be
covered with her here's an extension of
self I believe
has power when I looked at the hair of
so many people lying tangled on the
floor it was like seeing earlier selves
and discarded personality tics made
manifest so I never threw it away my
system swept it into a heap then bottled
it to keep on shelves in the back room